hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to rocket League now this is
a game where you play soccer with cars
and if you don't believe that soccer or
football should be played with cars
you're absolutely wrong this game is
overwhelmingly positively rated I'm
gonna be playing online and I have no
idea how to play all I know is that I
really want to so here we go searching
for standard and chaos in the Midwest
yep that sounds about right
also like whoa all right then I didn't
mean to do anything all right oh oh oh I
have no idea what I'm doing I was at
first ready for some reason all I know
is how to go and that's all I'm gonna do
my team's gonna lose probably I don't
know what these these things do whoa
missed it okay by that much walking oh
he's good
wait was I the goalkeeper whoopsies
sorry did not know that I should
probably try to keep goals and whatnot
whoa I was I was almost there hang on
wait a second we're gonna laugh sorry
I'm not in the goal oh I hope that's not
my job hang on a second here oh this is
intense my god
I did something oh good how do we how we
do all the things there no that's how I
do it good oh [ __ ] I didn't know I could
do this oh God whoops okay trick moves
aren't my thing
whoop damn it again I need to walk okay
scuse me pardon me sorry
okay this is not going as I planned it
do whoa oh sorry I gave you a boost
I helped maybe I don't know oh I don't
think anybody knows what they're doing
in this game and that's awesome I'm
upside down now wait
thanks for the boost where is it Oh Oh
God oh not that way not that way not
that way not that way I didn't mean to
do that didn't mean to do that
whoa thank you sir Wow oh crap this
isn't good this game is amazing this
game is like Tibet yeah yeah that's
right got it
I did that no one told me you could die
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I'm I hope
I'm doing right where is it no no no no
no no yeah there you go Danny where's
all the teammates are they all dead they
might be dead yeah here yeah that's
right get out there cheers mate
pardon me oh all of my defensive
maneuvers were for not hungry oh no my
team except forget bad not me of course
oh no [ __ ] damn it oh boy
elbow elbow elbow okay going wrong way I
need to be doing this I'm so bad I don't
know if I'm bad or everyone else is bad
this game is amazing Oh touch my tralala
poink oh god damn those cool yeah
defense okay I went the wrong way and no
wait
oh not where I'm supposed to be okay
hope nothing happened while I was up in
the air whoa okay whoa okay these guys
try to wreak on my team
no you don't that's right now oh it's
like they're working together or
something oh good day that's hardly fair
oh great pass great suck ass good swap -
whoop Dee whooping - whoa I'm going to
ram my car into now missing balls why am
i going the wrong way
where are they going what am I going oh
okay God if this was a real sport
if only this was a real sport yes we can
still win this there's plenty of time on
the clock
that ain't good that ain't good ain't
ain't good prolly play defensively if
I'm from far away all right this time
I'm gonna wash here we go I'm getting F
see screw you screw you screw all of you
oh crap this isn't where I'm supposed to
be yeah there we go
got it I'm the best I'm the best I'm the
best oh I like this much why did I jump
oh boy okay there we go I did good you
don't owe
yeah yeah oh crap that would a gun yes
yes yes yes yes Wow
I think I also had a hand in that but
that's you know whatever cool it's team
effort oh I touched it first if I hadn't
jumped so soon I might have done that a
little bit better here we go here we go
here we go oh hey get out here that's
right
wink okay go teammate go whoa no
teammate no yes No
bonk get out here no no no no no no [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and I
oh man well holy crap awesome it was so
cool there was so much fun
I'd like to snowman antenna oh oh oh it
was good oh man there's so much fun I
can't even describe how much fun but
that was so cool I can see why it's
raining too overwhelmingly positive now
okay so that's all I'm gonna play for
now if you want to see more games I
would love to play this game some more
let me know down in the comments below
and also I just want to say thank you
guys for being so patient with me as I
took my little break there I know that I
you know I don't go with outgoing videos
and I know this video was coming out
late for you guys but you know after the
grump charity livestream last night that
I didn't even know that I was gonna be
joining but they asked me and I was more
than happy to won't lend my time to that
you know I wasn't able to record games
last night so I was just doing it I was
trying to get your recording today but
also I was trying to get some sleep and
relax a little bit
sorry South Korea hey this snowman is
too cool so just thank you guys so much
for the patience you know it's not about
like the work of making videos that's a
problem it's just you know something
happened in real life that kind of put
me in a funk and it's you know it's not
so much to work it's about that you guys
are really smart and you can pick up
when I'm not gonna fully enjoy myself
you know I tried to be as honest as
possible with you guys so you know I
wasn't in the mood to make an
entertaining video and I can't fake
enthusiasm I can't fake entertainment
although maybe if I was playing this
game I might because it was so cool but
you know it's just you know I want to
make sure that these videos are good for
you guys and I want to make sure they're
good for me too so just thank you
everybody who understood that I just
need a little bit of a breather but
either way things will be back on track
tomorrow eight and twelve
everyday unless into the foreseeable
future like unless something else
significant comes up nothing is gonna
happen so thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for watching this
video thanks for watching also for a
third time and if you want to see more
let me
the comments below playas gave her
yourself it's fine thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next day life can just melt away